ecco si sono pronto a farlo non mi
ricordo bene ai fattori oggi finalmente
arrivato il grandissimo già rotto 6 dopo
aspettando po più playtime 2 conoscere
moltissimi tifosi abbiamo bar milan
mente anche altri personaggi non lo
abbiamo ancora visto niente siamo super
curiosi di vedere come sarà come sempre
mettetevi comodi preti poco lasciato un
bel mi piace qua sotto e iniziamo subito
l'avventura siena
è iniziato è qualcuno ha messo una casa
a creta quindi immagino che vedremo
qualcosa adesso qualche spoiler di
quello che sta per succedere fu che
cos'è questa credo che sia la mano di
mami long l'ex
e la pubblicità di mont milon blacks
perché sapete tema milan blacks era un
giocatolo
poi è successo qualcosa che scopriremo
sicuramente questo nuovo gioco e anche
carina
bra cattiva ma chissà che cosa sospetta
e così come allora ero troppo emozionato
di vedere come bright eyes nota come
l'ultimo spettatori barbara corridoio di
un otello siamo dove dove l'uomo
liberato poco vi ricordate nel primo
gioco di a chivu a chi abbiamo liberato
la bambola di poppi qua anche se non
dovevamo liberarla perché era molto
pericolosa e abbiamo scoperto che anche
i luoghi la stava sorvegliando e quindi
ora siamo di nuovo qua nella fabbrica
dei giocattoli poppi playtime e colleghi
ma chi è questo nuovo gioco fortunato
cazzo lo scopriremo un dinosauro
coraggio sarà troppo emozionata di
essere ancora qua della fabbrica di
giocattoli questo è uno dei miei giochi
preferiti perché è fatto su per bene
finito
pauroso e clag il rito lato si tra
bracciano da solo e un po roma allora si
stia strizzando tifosi non parlo per
togliere l'acqua ei dove sei anni ma che
sono portati elliot ludwig e chi è non
vedo l'ora di cosa che faccio un buco
qui dove stai andando qua devo passare
dall'altra parte
salta noda fa non ci passo dopo prendere
qualcosa allora con la ricorsa
wow ma già popolare adesso arriva la
visita parlare quindi ora con le mani
facciamo tipo tarzan
[Musica]
sembra
ha detto qualcuno quello un abbraccio
uno sviluppo
no non vogliamo un approccio da quando
va bene
ha scoraggiato
marrazzo perché il francese credo forse
dobbiamo passare quasi
post a parte di donne
la
testa va devi passare da in prima che
arrivi ma come si possono spostare con
la mano anche non per forza certo
se come un po di sangue pub è successo
qualcosa perché giocattolo così una
chiave è una chiave gigante
e una chiave con il fiore di poppi
quindi vuol dire che dovrà buttarla per
aprire qualcosa che ha a che fare con la
bambola pochi vi ricordate che dovevamo
seguire il fiore che era il gira proprio
questi motori che cosa succede ma
praticamente mio cliente lo posso
neanche avuto la mano qua vabbè fa
niente dovete promettere questa chiave
quando si può passare tornare indietro
un prodotto ornate di vetro studiamo
adoro troppo e troppo contenta che è
riuscito questo gioco
voi siete contenti alla fine il video
scriveteci qual è stato il vostro
personaggio preferito in questo nuovo
capitolo di poppi playtime ovviamente la
stato un bel mi piace perché se questo
video angeli 5 mila mi piace faremo una
seconda parte cui con lei anni gioca o
no qui c'è un giocattolo è stato
sfracellato tiro ma chi sembra un robot
questi sembrano i pad dove appoggiare le
mani sì però sono spenti forse dobbiamo
attivare l'elettricità allora ok
cerchiamo qualcosa per attivare
l'elettricità dove sarà l'elettricista
siamo parte la porta rossa olio ottenuto
brighi chi è questo un personaggio è una
statua di d'isidoro la presa ok non lo
so perché da sole sono tanti disegnini e
carini guardie che se messi il dinosauro
sembrano tipo disegni di bambini che
ancora non sapevano che in realtà questi
giocatori uno malefici ai paurosi ho
guardate o di umori e che se messi
innamorati sembrano così dolce mario non
lo so ok ho preso la cassetta questo
governo c'era scritto qualcosa lì forse
ora controlliamo vediamo nella cassetta
cosa sia anche l'altra 6326 svelato la
fabbrica dei giocattoli voglio saperlo
ha detto che il proprietario eliot
ludwig l'altro me
e lui sia creato tutti i giocattoli
fossero suo ufficio a tantissime ore
nella pausa nel 1960 è morta la sua
famiglia ma lui ha continuato a lavorare
alla fabbrica fino a cassetta senza è
rotto all'improvviso stava continuando a
raccontare la sua storia dicendo come ha
fatto a continuare a creare giocattoli
dopo la strage di andiamo in tolto e poi
ha detto e tutto iniziato nel 1900 che
s'è interrotto sicuramente qualche
indizio qualcosa che dovremmo fare dopo
ho dati ci sono delle mani quindi forse
dobbiamo andare da quella parte proprio
così si muove si tira tira è vero o no
ai video successo lì ho paura che ci sia
già oggi moltissimi stimano sono le luci
dei tunnel ma l'altra volta incontrava
anche chi si è visti qua e questi rossi
e si ragionerà proprio questo tunnel
un'altra area della particella letto il
bottone
che c'è chi guarda te ha detto stavo
provando riattivare l'elettricità qua
metto il rischio aiutare
possiamo tirarci secondo voi dalla
bambola popping l'uso
forse lo sapete che in realtà sembra
così carina e dolce in realtà è
pericolosissima però credo che dobbiamo
per forza attivare l'elettricità quando
ci sono questi tubi
no qui c'è scritto due quindi
dell'iniziale dalla so però non mi devo
vicino a lei usare la mano ebbene meno
male ok vediamo come si fa si
è poi questo vediamo se anche il resto
bravo ci sono riusciti a subito non ci
credo vediamo che abbiamo mattinata un
elettore giro
ha detto voglio ringraziarti perché sono
stata bloccata qua nella fabbrica per
tantissimo tempo i tubi e liberato
dove ha detto voglio ringraziarti
aiutandoti a scappare perché c'è una
stazione dei treni qua vicino una
stagione di treni possiamo finalmente
sto presa da
lei mi sta osservando
anche qui bisogna salire forza ai circa
cento è difficilissima questa cosa
ora vediamo se poi si fa a pezzetti
piano però è perché questa è pisano un
po paura se fanno un po paura che
all'improvviso
ieri rossi e ma
solo tu mi hai detto dove guardarla
sembra sembra così carina ho detto
dovresti essere in grado di seguirli
attraverso le condotte d'aria comunque
poppi sembra una bambola normalissima e
super carica si perora sistemo fidando
di lei ma che tranquilli noi facciamo
bene affidarsi però di ma non riusciamo
a passare noi fa non mi fa passare da lì
fermi la bambola è piccola e sono
garante
e magistrale passava da lì perché
piccoli non ci arriva ma vediamo cosa
forse ma qui hanno distrutto tutto
attenti a non cadere a mi devo
agganciare la sopra vediamo se ci riesco
a ribò sfracella mento compiuto abbiamo
iniziato qui non dobbiamo fare tutto
daccapo per fortuna rifacciamo
tardano
a queste porte sono chiuse dove dovrò
andare ad essere qui c'è un altro
giocatore un po spiaccicato uomo era
tipo un gatto e un ape
strano qua c'è qualcosa cos'è un altro
vento non mi fa passare però qua proprio
aprire questa porta
ecco la coppia ma questi famosi c'è un
buco ii e iii poppi che fai qua
ascoltava
provino un break preso conferire dovevo
andare a salvarla subito
comunque mi ha detto ascoltami e vivi
nardò di me anche se ancora non sappiamo
se possiamo fidarci di lei e poi bambino
presa l'ha portata a zumbo quindi noi
dobbiamo andare il giorno credo di si fa
un po paura però
no
ma è tutto buio sembra di sì stiamo
precipitando
non mi
sembrava tipo quei tubi di parchi
acquatici che alle scendi con la shamel
aspetta wow allora ci abbiamo la
stazione dei treni e da dove dobbiamo
scappare
elliot forse questi sono tre sono questi
nomination ai creatori della fabbrica
non lo so allora mentre città ok allora
devo nuovamente attivo di mettere
veramente ci riesco allora
che cosa quello è un po strano se
attivato qualcosa guarda che prova
vitale a risolvere questo caso non
abbiamo che i path or questi con
l'elettricità sono solo uno di più utili
sono divertenti no non ha funzionato
questa non puoi passare ma come si deve
fare allora ok allora avevamo fatto bene
solo che non eravamo arrivati con la
mano li ad attivarlo ora ci siamo
riusciti questo puzzle e radici ficci
la mia macchina sia arrivata dovete
andare ha detto eccolo si sono pronto
per giocare
o
no torino che non meno male per ora
siamo ancora vivi cosa c'è lì una alla
mano rossa
allora mi basta cliccare
stavano di bambino ha trovato una mano
o no adesso prodotti poppi
e inquietantissimo
allontanate
mamma mia che brutta
come sia un uomo che sembra un rai
dice perché noi giochiamo si
tenta voglio prendere a poppi poverino
povero che
obbedisce alla regola o ti farò a
pezzetti
e chi mangerò
diciamo che come minaccia ha detto ma
milan l'ex che devo superare una serie
di prove se voglio riuscire a scappare e
prendere il codice del biglietto della
stazione dei treni libertà per scappare
con la prima fabbrica che ha scoperto
che popi ci voleva dare ci voleva
aiutare a farci scappare insieme col 3 e
per quello che la presa
se stai facendo quindi dobbiamo scappare
dobbiamo anche salvare for paper che
sembra che sia innocente quello italiano
guarda chi un bottone lì
questi bottoni scorretto
credo che abbia finito la batteria
finora adoro questo gioco adoro troppo
l'ambientazione le corse paura è troppo
bello a proposito di cose paura avete
già preso dottore paolo iii scuola di
misteri sono rimasti ancora delle copie
con la cartolina firmata da me è vitale
ma non so quando ancora saranno
disponibili se volete ricevere la coppia
con la cartolina firmata da me evitare
ordinatelo subito su amazon perché non
so quando finiranno quindi se volete
accaparrarvi la cartolina kinkade linke
descrizione ordinatelo subito vi piacerà
tantissimo vedrete se volete inviati
mila foto con il libro su instagram e vi
mando un saluto mi sembra di vedere che
ok qui c'è il treno c'è bisogno di una
mano verde a noi piace una mano verde il
rosso a mano sia perfetto ap c'é un
altro bottone non lo avevo visto
proviamo suonare
questa eclissi messi che dice sto per
partire il treno crocchette parti qui ci
sono tre leve problemi tirarla una
che hai fatto
benvenuti alla stazione dai giochi che
sono stesso ma dove questa persona per
mezzo
delle casse e josè sta si sta aprendo
qualcosa
non aiuta dove gioca visto ricordo ok
quindi questa è la nostra prima prova di
mobil all blacks che dobbiamo superare
penso proprio ad ora trovo mai fatto
vivo vediamo se siamo bravi o creare con
la memoria
io infatti per quello che mi spaventavo
aiutateci voi partecipate al gioco
assieme a noi vediamo se è riuscito poi
a memorizzare il tutto c'è un altro
esatta espressione sia per tu qualcosa
qui a male faccio un corridoio quasi una
volta li vediamo sempre lavorato molto e
vi rinuncia quindi dovremo passare da
parlare immagino questa parte della
pubblica
mi stavo male che esiste nessuno si apre
le ci sono delle bombole per quale
motivo non lo voglio sapere ok
continuiamo la bara ora che sta dentro
al buco non è che spunta fuori ma milo
blacks all'improvvisa no io credo che
vada ad host bus e mandando sotto terra
non lo so
questo gioco
qui è un po buio finché room dove fanno
le forme per preparare i giocattoli
a tutto che la gente aspetta perché
vorrei accendere la luce alberelli
riguardo nata proprio andare lì mamma ho
paura che adesso spunta fuori qualcuno
le società sono perfetto vestito ma tipo
quelli della fabbrica che la conoscevamo
un pochettino dall'altro pop plein air
allora vediamo ci sono quattro pulsanti
qui ci sono delle mani milano roberta
sono un sacco di manila questo che cos'è
è ciò che sembra una cella prego non a
tor strano qui ci sono delle cose rosse
dove c'è un bottone per ho aspettato si
sta illuminando che sei proprio amo
vedere che cos'è è una goccia
fringe la cassetta spetta
dove sarà il videoregistratore ora non
c'è il videoregistratore a cui guarda ok
vediamo forse ci dà le istruzioni al
primo già sappiamo adoro video
[Musica]
la mano barete sì ma dov'è ottenere
elettricità con la mano ben capito per
dire in secondi
quindi ha una funzione dopo una mano
elettrificata
che ci sono delle porte che si aprono
con solo con la mano verde che elettrica
sì però si è capito bene datemi una mano
ben aspetta magari esce qui a fianco non
stai attento potresti essere spiaccicato
dalle porte
senso allora ok però da terminavano
verde traversa riuscirà qua c'è un
pulsante e bene potrebbe e non secondo
la mano verde
aspetta aspetta aspetta questa macchina
qui alle forme delle mani si le ho viste
prima ovvero quando so come facciamo a
prendere dobbiamo premere qualche
pulsante aspetta forse questi sono i
prototipi dove le stampano un'altra
parte 3d non sei il più bravo forse per
dire i bottoni che bocca cosa c'era il
primo boccone un bottone che si illumina
quando
vedi che felice anche la mano sì quindi
questo devo fare allora proviamo con
questo primo bottone che
cosa sono
forse il materiale che si scioglie per
fare
a creando un omaggio di più di questo
tubo allora come si possa dire su è come
faccio anche loro
si è sciolto e adesso andrà nell'altra
macchina penso di sì
fighissimo devo proprio una bufala
guarda
ok adesso basta lo sta premendo vedi che
figo
ma lo stiamo creando lavoro di plastica
troppo bello
l'affido abbia staccato vedi
dato che ho fatto cinque che possiamo
fare 5 anno magari dove state andando
aspetta aspetta è stato proprio qui e
devo provare un altro pulsante forse
sono rimasti aspetta sta suonando vede
vediamo ora che succede
ehi che dice no 20 machine
bisogna mettere la vernice
aiuto aiuto aiuto perché c'è questo
rumore strano c'è arrivato qualcuno
aiuto non mi dire che è arrivato a chi
manchi proprio vedere la tia trovato
delle luci accese adesso questi rumori
in tanti andiamo a cercare la pernice
queste porte erano chiuse prima
vennero ok saliamo farle lo prevediamo
se c'è la vernice a si sono tipo
attivati io l'ho mai provata è
accorto che quel che si accende una luce
devo ammetterlo qua
ministro funzionato da storia la
fabbrica e posso scendere da qua e penso
di sì o no il rullo mi sta trasportando
a questa parte non vuole essere dipinta
poi è finito verde perfetto proprio
fisico
il vento troppo bello creato la fabbrica
è chiusa forse bisogna farlo uscire
fuori vedi sì
ecco la ora ma era un altro buttate ora
proviamo ad attivare con questa
manovra
ma la mano di arredamento elettrica e
adesso potrei dare qualcosa che appena
dietro dietro temi di pietro e passando
il bottone detenute
vai vai vai primo che mi spiace
aspetta aspetta adesso c'è chi perché
adesso siamo di nuovo nei miei corridoio
dove vucinic l'ordine nel primo gioco
pulse i banchi waki quindi stiamo
[Musica]
ma siamo sicuri e ancora non riuscire a
nessuno ma avrebbe sudando le mani che
quest'anno lega il carrellino che
abbiamo questo prima cosa prima quel
girasole un altro personaggio guardai
tipo un coniglio gatto
a essere un gatto con lui ha detto somma
del tuo compleanno juniors ben 28 giugno
no no non è il mio compleanno dando poi
burning sea rincitrullire rincitrullito
quel coniglio il vostro compleanno il 28
giugno se il vostro compleanno allora e
con il miur indovinato sembra che possa
andare solo qua
non bobina che cos'è che ora scusa che
succede aiuto che cosa sono questi
tanti schermi
benvenuto va al musical memory vediamo
cosa sei in veloce ad utilizzare un
cervello aiutateci anche voi davvero una
squadra di colori e dobbiamo ricrearla
il bonzo
quindi bonzano alcuni gli ho detto che
monza si avvicina piano piano
[Musica]
se bonzo si avvicina e
la loro buona fortuna se bontà si
avvicina del tutto ci speri accica aiuto
che ansia ok però è troppo divertente
to be bop nome
ma guardo le sta scendendo
inquietante
aiuto
e aiutati a rosati non ho ancora
iniziato bonzo non pagati
buona fortuna non siamo milan backstage
per fortuna è tornato su eccola lì mi
sto guardando da lì bronzo red
ok
finora è facile
no ero al rosso
rosso verde
rosso verde journal
[Musica]
quindi il rosso
verde giallo giallo giallo
regole berlin giallo giallo blu
finora tutto ok è ritornato sul rosso
rosso blu
rosso che anzi
blu
perché financing di red blu
rosso blu
grigio
molto ma ci facciamo più ruote o
sotto blu rosso non mi ricordo
a ci spiace capo così
ok ragazzo dimostrazione brucia in
trazione non distraiamoci questa volta
non perda il verde blu verde
blu verde rosso
[Musica]
blu verde
green e dove viola dove viene percorsa
l'abbiamo fatta
sta tornando sul terzo round
ma sta aggiungendo il tricolore o no
biancoverde no devi ripetere sempre
quindi bianco verde
[Musica]
blu blu
blu
[Musica]
blu blu
blu
blues dei blu come j geni signora pure
l'aiuto
blu blu
del cuore
o no
allora blu blu j j cuore
blu
blu blu blu gery j forest
blu blu sentiremo sempre golfino
blu un ara blu dei
cuori rubati in auto blu
pi greco
orange
no ancora no
[Musica]
corsa veloce tanto
avendo niente
quello lì proprio quello lì forse quello
che ci sarà
non è possibile non sapendo cosa voglio
rifare tutto da capo
non vale per futuro losito bechar la
signora tutto da capo
si è rotto ha detto che siccome siamo
stati bravi ci darà una parte del codice
per il treno potrebbe prenderlo beh
forse lo devi prendere della sua mano
abbiamo messo la mani
[Musica]
speravo che il gioco continuasse ancora
più più io no ma mi sa altri modi per
giocare con te hai un altro gioco
mortale dove dobbiamo scriverla dobbiamo
dare adesso comunque ragazzi è stato
molto ansioso ma è bene che questo gioco
è fatto troppo bene wow sono scioccato
da quanto è bello
noi dovevamo scappare da qui e
venire un
aiuto
[Musica]
ci sono dei rumori strani qui non si
girava tutti girare più paura quanto
sincero non c'è nessun ok sembrano i
rapimenti di rho blocks però fatto
meglio lo siamo ma devo buttarmi qua che
penso proprio di sì se fossimo ai
giocattoli wow bel debutto ricevuto né
e così nota un rinnovo del minotauro
laggiù per fortuna non si muove quindi
forse non è malefico stare qui c'è un
bottone verde quindi quelli che si
caricano dove andrà
che un uso estranee che è questa ha
lasciato lo stadio costo questo che
risultino savo prima riprendo
l'elettricità e poi mi devo sbrigare
no non riesco a dire un fa ma mila un
nesso il gioco di bambino blacks
quell'originale non prima che lei
diventasse un esperimento malefico
ci sono tanti giochi qua che bello
guarda qui c'è tutto c'è un
videoregistratore dovevo vedere l'altra
parte di uno guarda che c'è qualcosa
che così si è attivato non lo so penso
che le scopriremo presto
è la cassetta non lo trovavo dai ragazzi
come questo primo episodio e lunghissimo
continuiamo nella parte ii lasciate un
mi piace per vedere la parte 2 è ora vi
lasciamo qua faccia caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
e cup e supportate preferite buona
visione ciao